[Music]
a political crisis in Iraq has erupted
into violence after the powerful Shiite
leader mukhtar al-sata announced he was
quitting Frontline politics gunfire and
explosions have rocked baghdad's high
security green zone in the past few
hours with reports of heavy fighting
between rival Shiite factions at least
20 people have been killed and hundreds
injured in the worst fighting the Iraqi
Capital has seen in years Victoria
gaytonby begins our coverage
chaos in baghdad's heavily fortified
green zone
foreign
[Applause]
factions targeting each other
the fighting escalated late on Monday
night after a day of violence and
political turmoil
[Applause]
protests broke out after Sheikh cleric
material Sada announced he was quitting
Frontline politics
[Applause]
his supporters broke into the
presidential Palace which houses the
prime minister's office
many even taking to the Palace pool
our demands are to dissolve parliament
and to hold the corrupt account and we
say my master muktada al-sader their
pride is under your feet and will
sacrifice for you Victory Is Ours
here take a prime minister Mustafa
Academy halted cabinet sessions until
further notice but Iraq's political life
was already in limbo there's been
deadlock for almost a year since
mctadarall said his party won the
largest share of seats in elections last
October
it wasn't enough to secure a majority
and Sada hasn't been able to form a
government of his choosing he told his
MPS to resign in June and his supporters
have been protesting since July some
even briefly occupied Parliament
they want new elections without the
participation of iran-backed groups
[Applause]
this is an Iraqi Revolution Iraq should
be returned to its people
has announced his retirement from
politics and many have dismissed it as a
bluff to gain leverage over his Rivals
already several protesters have been
killed and hundreds wounded
and it's feared sada's latest move could
lead to yet more instability
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
a lot of correspondent Mahmoud Abdul
Wahid is in Baghdad
we're now very close to the green zone
where the clashes is continuing between
uh armored brigades uh Affiliated to the
southern on the one hand and on the
other hand the military units they say
the southern supporters say that the the
the the Army groups shooting at them are
affiliated to the popular mobilization
forces we cannot independently verify
that but we know for certain that
caretaker prime minister amusable
Academy earlier Warner Security Forces
not to use live bullets against
protesters there have been sniper shots
coming from on top of the building if
you can if you if you've just heard this
explosion we've been hearing explosions
several explosions uh many people here
say that probably motor Rockets or a
rocket probably grenades fired in the
area in and around the green is on the
situation equation remains very tense as
you know that it's ironic because the
green zone which is a battlefield now
between the Rival factions has been the
heavily Fortified Area that is home to
government offices and international
diplomatic missions including the U.S
embassy and the uh the embassy of the UK
Jabari is in Tehran with more on how the
Iranian government is reacting to the
violence in Baghdad
well we heard from officials in Iran who
have advised their citizens not to
travel to Iraq they have also
um canceled all flights to Iraq as a
result of the instability that is
ongoing in that country there's a travel
advisory Hall Iranian citizens to avoid
travel to the country they have also
closed all the land border crossings
between Iraq and Iran of course the two
countries our neighbors and they share a
very long border that stretches about
1300 kilometers as we also heard from
the foreign Ministry spokesperson a
little earlier this evening and he said
that the Iranian government believes
that there is no political impacts that
Iraq can't solve itself and that the
Iranians are recommending that Iraq and
pursue a solution to political
misunderstandings that they're having
based on its Constitution which is
interesting of course because one of the
main issues that is at the core of the
dispute between Southern supporters and
the government is the Constitution
itself and the laws that have been put
in place about the system of government
that they have
um has been a crucial figure in Iraqi
politics for a long time the Shiite
Leader's satirist movement is one of the
most powerful factions he rose to
prominence after the end of Saddam
Hussein's leadership in 2003 he's
demanded the departure of American
troops and is against Iran's influence
his movement secured the top position
after parliamentary elections in October
last year winning 73 seats but neither
he nor his Rivals had enough seats for a
majority after months of failing to form
a government Sarah ordered his MPS to
resign in June and his supporters have
protested in central Baghdad since July
briefly occupying Parliament
Albert wolf is a research associate at
Johns Hopkins University he isn't
shocked by Sarah's announcement
frankly I think this is sadder being
solder uh I do believe that this is
um I wouldn't call it a stunt per se but
I do believe that he is he's jockeying
for leverage
um in this current political crisis
the past two elections have yielded the
same exact results you know they've uh
you know is not you know and one of the
things that's pushing him is that he has
not been able to get a prime minister of
his choosing the coordination you know
one of the things that he demanded was
that the coordination framework
nominates someone who was quote unquote
independent from Nuria Maliki that's one
thing that's pushed this and the second
thing is is that
um you know he's resisting of you know
in you know us and Iranian influence
um so these are a couple of the things
that are pushing this but these are
tactics that stuff is used since 2003.
well I don't believe that he's retiring
from politics and I don't believe
anybody else believes that either
um he's also said he's going on a hunger
strike
um so
um you know solder is one of the few if
if not the only figure in the Iraqi
public sphere who could summon hundreds
of thousands of people onto the onto the
streets literally literally
um so I I think that I think that you're
in for as you mentioned in your question
another election I think that the
election will probably result in a very
similar result as the last two elections
and probably with you know low voter
turnout if not lower voter turnout than
the last two